okay go again
okay we're gonna watch her hip turn go
good you got it and now what you're
thinking
is hip rotation
that's what she's thinking okay
um
who can guess what's gonna happen when i
add resistance to this line
do you see do you see that
do you see that okay why is that
happening
what is newton's law about
the force going that way and i have this
opposite equal angle right
she has no base over here you see that
so she goes
she has no base over here we got that
so as she goes into his
technique with that you can and you're
gonna go slow
you're gonna step into this foot you're
gonna put it back you see
so what's happening now as you go just
let go ahead for a second stay there
andrew as you go to turn your hips
you see you're picturing hip power
but what's happening is his weight
is pulling on that base where there is
no base
okay and so he goes and you
have you feel like ah okay
got the idea all right so
uh here is your drill
um you're going to do
your you can't you're going to take your
noggin like that
every time so you can separate your feet
you got it
okay and my job is not to go
okay as she goes
you're going to try your hardest i want
you to try your hardest
get me down so you see
not going to happen hold your grip hold
your grip
and i i have her face okay because she
has no legs
so that's our drill you're gonna go
really hard
and pull you're just never gonna get it
okay try it so uh this is big man aikido
you see because you're just trying to
overpower the person
so um she's gonna go really try to get
him down
separate your feet like that again and
use your hip rotation
okay and now let's change rolls
okay and you get her down okay
see it'll work it's big man aikido
um he can generate enough force
to overcome her resistance okay
but that's not jiu-jitsu let alone
aikido
okay um now
next thing we do okay the next thing we
want to do
is uh let's not
make the guy uh
resist or stay still
okay you got it because there's a rule
here
where a guy is pushing i
turn okay so
if you reverse engineered the technique
i was
turning then by default we know uke was
what
we're pushing okay um
so uh okay is going to push
and let's just use the same uh weird
foot maneuver
where i separate my feet okay so i go
like this
and i go like this and then uk is gonna
push
and i'm going to absorb that
go in the turn okay
that's where i just want to try that now
uke
is going to push
in the turn i'm going to try to get it
down
again okay let's do that experiment
so i'm doing the technique i take this
down skirt you see it
okay now he pushes
and then i have some energy that i could
at least
deal with some of his mass you got the
idea
okay but let's understand
the engineering need for ura
so when he pushes and i go
here where is he supposed to push
into me not around
okay so his angle goes here
now i'm gonna he can go slow make sure
you're not going around me
he's pushing into me and i'm
trying to do the technique now okay
i go this thing
pushes into me
it's not going to go around me like i
think he is
okay so uh
you'll be doing that as you can okay so
the first time you were just here you're
going like no
okay we'll give some energy but we give
the right
energy and the right energy is not
around
him
the right energy is into him
okay try it yeah okay
let's make the next experiment when a
guy is coming
in to me he has ill intent
okay either to counter my maneuver or to
attack me
okay um
but here's what happens some people come
in
leave their feet there don't move your
feet
it can't move okay but he kind of comes
in
then it'll work okay
it looks like it's going to work but why
does it work
because he didn't move his feet he
doesn't move his feet
looks like it'll work okay
instead let's just uh look at
why i come in so as i did the first
experiment and he tries to turn and here
i was resisting
right there's not a very
good resisting angle so we want a better
resisting angle
and that is achieved go ahead by coming
in
to him you see he tries to do the
technique he's even weaker
so he's even weaker
okay uh so when i come in
i want to put my feet under
not leave him behind and let him stretch
you
so he goes i come in
get out of the way and i just move
he's never gonna get it okay
that's why we come in i'm resisting
in a mechanically sound way posting my
legs
and keep moving forward okay so go
towards him
bring your feet with you don't leave
your feet there
and go towards him okay try it now let's
look at
something that you might be thinking
if he could get the elbow under him
then he could be stronger and get me
down well that's a big if
because if i keep moving he can't get
the elbow under him
okay but let's allow it
i came in you see my elbow turn around
put it right under you separate your
feet put your foot back
that's our style there you go okay
and he's going to push down
he's got to overcome the leg see go
ahead
so let's say i go here go ahead
go ahead he he can't because the legs
the legs are just too strong for his
size to me
okay someone may be a little smaller
he could maybe do it but again that's
not jiu-jitsu
let alone it's not aikido okay
overpowering is not what we're doing
okay
all this comes from
this this
this footwork okay
we don't want that footwork we want to
be right here
right here feet underneath me
okay so let's have him
come in feed underneath me he goes
i'm just gonna move it around he's not
going around
okay right behind his elbow he comes in
you see he's not going around he comes
in
to make him go around
boom stay here
when you feel this just maybe
okay
okay try it okay so there now
has to be a skill set it's another
internal skill
okay um let's say he's pushing on me
you're
really pushing you often look like
you're not pushing
people people don't realize how much
energy there is okay
so he's pushing and i'm going to get the
ground
vector but not in a bracing angle
he's pushing and you won't push long so
drive okay
and i don't need the front foot for that
he's grounding the front the back foot
do you see those
since i don't have a bracing angle it's
just a ground path
just a ground path it doesn't matter
what my other foot is do
okay so
when i go to this technique
if i can't take that energy into the
ground
what happens is my axis of rotation
starts to get thrown backwards as i push
him around
can you get it so as he's coming in
slower
he's coming into me and i'm attempting
to push him around
that energy is coming back to me if i
can't ground it it makes me move
that's what you think why you put that
foot here
but that foot causes all those other
problems
as you try for the rotation
so his energy that comes into me
keeps pushing it's all going into the
ground
keep going it's going into the ground
see a little harder and that's what i
come on dude that's what i take
around me okay
so i do need this internal skill
that's called q he's pushing
that goes not onto my heels does not
move me
it goes down through the mid foot into
the ground and that's what
i said around me
well you can see
that part's not important the ground
part he's pushing
pushing that's what i'm doing
okay try it again
so maybe you got here
and then you want to put this underneath
you and do the other technique
where you're trying to overpower him but
he was coming into me and there's no
angle of deflection on this one
you don't get on top you get close-up of
the hands
this is incorrect incorrect incorrect
if he was coming at you he's going to
still keep coming at you
okay so your deflection is
out out he's turned this way
here do you see out
not on top out
boom we'll add the technique now
you see here
not here here
he goes i'm going to find it even easier
he goes
try it uh so as he goes
and he feels that going around he should
try to get his foot in there
you see so i can't shut that thing down
he doesn't leave his feet there and then
i go
and no
he's trying to come in then he counters
do you see
so the first thing i have to do is on
the initial projection
is i turn with it so i keep facing
it
boom he's coming in
keep facing so i'm turning with
it
you're going to then feel his foot so
we'll go slow
that's his energy coming this way i make
it go out
and i'm going to feel that foot it's
going to push up on my elbow
okay when i feel that upward energy
[Music]
that's what i keep lift it up you see
when i feel the upward energy that's
what i think around again
so the initial energy goes around
the upward energy goes around again
[Music]
he's falling he's
falling
[Music]
do you see and i'm staying with him i
will not stay with him this time
you see there's energy
i'm not pushing him down
[Music]
just stay with it don't let
this gap happen you see
lower yourself
and keep that connection let's try it